clumsy coach Davos 20 in Alabama alum
taking down the tide for the second time
in three years and this time around it
didn't take a final play a deshaun
Watson magic act it was a it was a
blowout
that's the magic nick saban worst loss
ever 44 to 16 unbelievable the last team
to beat Alabama by 16 or more points was
LSU when Nick Saban was the head coach
oh my goodness it was nasty it was ugly
and Peter's you said earlier the big
players for Alabama didn't step up the
big players for Clemson did including a
literally big guy six foot six inch true
freshman Trevor Lawrence who now has to
wait two years to go to the NFL I think
the NFL would take him right now oh no
question about it Mike and I think you
know this is going to be a story over
the next few weeks over the next few
months probably approaching this year's
draft for a very simple reason that when
a guy looks that precocious and that
good you have to just say is there real
reason for this rule now the NFL is
going to point to excuse me player
development and what the college game is
and their relationship with college
football and I look at this and I say I
do understand that but I also look at it
and say that here's Trevor Lawrence he's
19 years old certainly he needs more
development no question about it but
after a year in which he threw for 30
touchdowns and only four interceptions
after a night which he was three
touchdowns no interceptions 347 yards
against Alabama looking every bit you
know the amazing thing in just in in you
know even and just watching the
highlights is how calm he was and you
know I was with Patrick mahomes the
other day and it's so interesting to
look at a lot of these young
quarterbacks Mike and to see how calm
they are and how prepared they are for
this level right now and look I mean
we're gonna debate this a lot probably
over the year over the next few months
but Clemson is very very lucky to have
this guy for the next two years yeah if
they have him for two years now I'm not
suggesting he should sit out the next
two years but I'll tell you what I would
do come back next year
win your Heisman Trophy go for another
national championship and then in 2020
say see you later Clemson I'm done
making you money I'm gonna commence the
process of preparing myself to go to the
NFL and make money and where we are
right now I think how things have
evolved with players not playing in
meaningless ballgames and the pendulum
has moved in that direction I think
we're ready for a high-end prospect
especially at quarterback to make the
conscious decision I'm not gonna break
my ankle I'm not gonna tear up my knee
I'm not gonna injure myself in a way
that's going to keep me from playing in
the NFL I'm gonna give college football
two years and if they're not gonna let
me in I'm gonna sit out a full year
Jadeveon Clowney was the first guy that
we that we really pushed that issue on
behalf of and I remember that last year
for him in South Carolina it felt like
he was conscious of injury that he
understands there's nothing to gain that
third year you're only making money for
someone else and I think that's what
Lauren should consider Peter well I'll
say this Mike I remember when Peyton
Manning went back for you know he had a
choice remember he could have been the
first draft choice overall in 1997 by
the New York Jets or he could go back to
school one more year and and be drafted
by whoever in 1998 and there's a lot of
urban legend about what Peyton Manning
thought and what he decided and
everything like that but I think at the
end of the day it came down to this when
you're 21 or 22 years old you love
football
you love college football it's all you
know and when you're a kid growing up
you don't say well at 19 and 20 I'm
gonna play college football and then
that third year I'm gonna sit out be
I want to save myself you know do you
know how much fun Trevor Lawrence must
be having right now it's got to be one
of the happiest kids in America and and
again I'm not saying he wouldn't do what
you suggested but some of this is not
just saving himself for his future some
of this is my gosh I'm having the time
of my life I'm not giving this up and
and very very few times I can think back
really only a couple of times like Greg
cook half century ago with the Bengals
suffered an injury so bad that he really
couldn't keep playing and so injuries
and and and and modern science Mike you
know III just don't see any kid giving
up an entire year Nick Bosa was a little
different this year right because I got
hurt got hurt yeah he got hurt and then
he said forget it I'm not gonna try to
race back and and blah blah I get that I
just I'm not I'm not saying I have no
idea I've never met this kid now III
don't know anything about his situation
but I would just be surprised if a kid a
teenager still looks two years ahead and
says well that's it I'm only playing
here one more year at that age you don't
look two weeks ahead I mean that's a
reality that's what benefits the college
football system you're in that bubble
that 18 to 23 year old bubble where you
think number one you're gonna live
forever number two you're always gonna
be able to do the things that you
currently can do and number three I'm
just living in the moment I don't care
about next week I don't definitely don't
care about next year screw next year I'm
gonna enjoy my life now and that that in
yours to the benefit of all these
college programs that are making
billions collectively on the efforts of
guys whoo-hoo yeah what am I gonna do
I'm not gonna play football I love
playing football go play football I'm
six foot six they can't hurt me
I'll be fine I've lived a charmed life
it's gonna continue to be charm
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports